i want to play a game with you before we
get out of here
is that you get asked the same just just
from like doing press with you you
yeah how about ask the same hack
questions
over and over again there's about four
of them that you can
ask over and over again and i want to
play a game with you called hack back
clap back where first you'll give the
hack answer that you have to give
because you don't want to hurt that
interviewer's
feelings because obviously they want to
be an actor but now they're hosting this
show
right and then you get the clap back
it's the real answer
no consequences it's not directed to any
person
if there's no consequence you could say
exactly
what you felt in that moment so first
you give the
pr answer and then you give the clap
back okay
so your first hack back clap back
question is okay
so harold and kubar this is the guy by
the way all right i know that guy
so you played heroic yoda white castle
i'm gonna ask are you gonna ask a
question gotta ask legally uh are you
high right now
oh i'm not i'm not you know i gotta have
a meeting
okay so that's the hack answer and now
you give the clap back question i gotta
ask you guys are you high right now
really high really really really high
i'm really high i'm really [ __ ] high
dude man you gotta give me some money
man come on
okay so you've had quite the interesting
career i mean cal
you went from white castle
to the white house i was out yeah
yeah it was you know it was such an
honor um
yeah it was i i'm just so glad that uh
you know the the i i am fortunate enough
to
have the chance to do a lot of the
things that i that i wanted to do i'm
i'm having a hard time answering these
moses because that is how i
feel let's get to it then let's get to
it before you say another word
what is the clapback question kelly you
went from the white house oh white
castle to the white house what was that
like
yeah that headline is not clever it's
not clever it's
every there's a i have a i have a
running tally with a couple of friends
i try to take a picture when i sometimes
when i do interviews
the the host you do it with will have
the prompter pulled up
and i can see about four seconds before
they introduce me
there's a thing that pops up is it all
oh
our next guest went from the white
castle to the white house
and they always do the head bob when
they go from one to the other
and uh it i die a little bit inside
um but it's also funny yeah it's also
funny because it's like yeah i mean
they're not
doing art there's no malice in there
yeah
yeah it's obama cool is he a cool guy
you see him he's dropping mike's
is he a cool guy account your scoliosis
huge dick actually no he's not he's not
but sometimes i say that just to watch
people's faces fall right
um and especially especially
uh especially drunk women which you know
obviously you're thinking how often do
you encounter drunk women you live in
manhattan it's thursday through sunday
yeah but that's always a fun one
because it comes from such a good place
of like oh look at the [ __ ] we're
dealing with now hey
you you know you work for obama like
tell me something good
and so when you when i just go dark with
like oh god no
they're watching their faces follow
those prices i pick it back up i pick it
up before i move on but
huge dick you know he's really into
youtube
and cyber bullying he's always got a
fidget spinner on you know
he's always chugging a monster energy
drink and that's obama's secret
okay cal last question for you you know
you're on a house right and it's always
medical jargon
if you're on a plane if someone's having
a allergic reaction to peanuts
do you ever you ever ever ever get asked
to step in
medically yeah
uh sometimes sometimes yeah
you've worked on house you learned all
that medical jargon here are you ever
forced to step in in a medical emergency
oh no oh no puppets out puppet can say
whatever he wants
can't cancel a puppet that was your
[ __ ] question
oh oh look how clever i am
i look at very [ __ ] clever mouse's
storm
it [ __ ] that's not that's not nice
i shouldn't miss it i'm not nice yeah
here i am just hustling
that's that's not necessary we can i
think we figured it out you got to bring
the puppet with you
the the fun thing about
that question recently is
um so i did a graduation speech at
quinnipiac university
i want to say two years three years ago
yeah you know
yeah well that's not a humble brag i got
paid money and i gave a speech
i did one i am available phoenix yeah
did you no like what you had very lucky
okay so when i show up there and it was
like it was really fun and i
enjoy doing these things and it's a fun
side gig
um they they gave me an honorary
doctorate
and so i have been trying to figure out
for the last two years
the next time i renew my driver's
license can i put
doctor instead of mr am i allowed to do
that
and my understanding is that
you sort of choose your title nobody
verify you have to send a diploma
but even if you did it's a thing that
says
it's honorary but it says you're an
honorary doctor
so like if he said all of us could do
that we could all go i could go
dr moses storm
but i am in fact a doctor and so
when somebody on a plane asks if there's
a doctor on board
i'm really familiar with the puppet
attempted to hit the button i want to
hit the button
it's no longer it's no longer the
overused question that people ask me
because i was on the house
it is now me really really wanting the
next flight i'm on
to have some sort of a medical emergency
just so i can introduce myself yeah as a
doctor
but what's the plan you actually get
there someone's like their necks blowing
up from a peanut allergy and you're just
gonna get the same
no and they're like they're like doctor
doctor what do we do
i'm like well i'm a i'm an honorary
doctor of letters
from quinnipiac university
i can talk to the patient the patient
can't talk he's dying
and then it's not a good outcome huh
the puppet gives mouth to mouth yeah
like i mean yeah yeah
it suddenly becomes a nathan for you
sketch with not a good outcome
right psycho cal pen yeah murders
patient
on your commercial flight that what a
time for it
this is really great talking to you
thanks gal